Puck ahead Crosby settles it down with the glove
throws it behind the net Russ can't get a stick
on it Patterson shot from the point drilled
wide Crosby off the back wall and now scores
missed on the first attempt to come up with the
puck got it a second time and Banks it off Elis
M leans below the goal line and Pittsburgh is on
the board everything is situated perfectly here
but the Puck's going to end up on Chris leang
stick right there and as he just unloads that
puck with speed Crosby gets it back that's a
bouncing Puck that gets chopped at by verono
right in front and as he misses it you can see
that play by Pon Crosby's got the worst angle he
could be at too I mean this is just hanging out
in the right area and then taking a swipe at the
puck and it's top shell here jackets break it up
down the wing with speed moving in Maro walks to
the front of the beheads and scores what a beauty
Maro with a terrific individual effort and we're
tied at one great job by the Blue Jackets Defender
proo standing up keep an eye on Fant Tilly 11 he's
going that backs off the defender just enough
and I think marchenko got a little lucky that
pucky Puck stuck with him right here got to have
a bounce once in a while and then he finishes
it off and we're tied up here in Columbus L
tro with his fourth goal penguin send it back
deep in front backhanded Elvis makes the save and
bounces through the goal M and the
jackets defend helping out their
goenda really been raving about them here they
showed a little Flex as they had offensive zone
time tracking down pox left wing looking at the
goal line jackets will swing it around the wall
up high is good Branson good Branson chinot
scores off the pad of jari and into the net
with 31 seconds left chinab with his first
of the season and the first at a long time
got that shot going and the blue Jacks did
a nice job of keeping Pucks in the zone good
Branson here again he's going to be a factor
he keeps that puck on the weak side wall how
many times have we seen this play as he gets it
down to chinik chinik rolls out way too much time
and space if you're the Penguins he rolls out
he picks his spot and it's perfect with boom
Jenner roov will gather it up settles it
down circles the net chips It Off the Wall
rust steps into him ginel able to keep it in
shot there Rael loose Puck and Elvis in the
blue paint will hold an intense play you can
see Raquel here just whips it in on Elvis he's
got a track back that Puck and there's blue
jerseys in front out of the Zone good row re
in the slot wrist it high and wide oh singer
thought he had it baking it off Christen jar
somehow that puck stayed out of the that was
behind jar and just someone collected that with
their stick another attempt here is blocked
anxious moments here this puck gets in around
jar there's that shot that goes wide and then
it's cylinder how about bemstrom sees it there
he tries to get his stick out he just misses it
backand Passat in front and gensel tipped it high
penguins moving that puck around the jacket
Zone again here from the slot backhanded and
scores H estrosa getting a stick on it may
have been deflected again that's gensel but
the penguins have tied it up how about that pass
by Crosby he just put on a clinic this whole ship
backhand pass earlier to over to L Tang here he
is on recovering that puck he's late in his ship
but he knows they're buzzing and as he gets his
Puck to the middle of the ice look who cleans it
up Jake [Applause] gensel Blue Jackets L coming
quickly L moves in and a bck stop there by jar
was moving one way got the pad around for sure I
think they really Embrace being in that atmosphere
there that at Madison Square Garden shot save M
Lans from the slot a penalty up coming here the
power play needs to get something going here for
this team and it's going to be Eller on Johnny
[Applause] cro Eller tosses to the corner behind
the net good Branson finishing a jack ell spun
around knocks down riny penguins have got it in
the slot shot save rebound another stop Elvis way
out of the net the net empty Penguins try to fire
it there but it's blocked by Veron COV leak here
let's see what happens he's locked in on this save
that puck pulls him out of the net you can see
now he gets drug out by the skates and here wow
Carlson didn't like what he saw thought he could
fake everyone out but baronov stayed right with
him and the big man blocked that shot Rael cross
the line picked up Malin in the slot off the goal
post Carlson is waiting on the near side he'll
get it here screen set in front of murin of Jenny
Malin Raquel back to Malin one timer by Carlson he
scores Penguins looking to set that up Carlson
just waited there and then drills it home Malin
comes right out and these guys go to work and it's
Puck possession and Raquel he's looking for one
guy and it's Malin and how about Malin there
he knows on the week side he's got Eric cson
as wide as you can possibly be look how backed
off he is he's outside the dot Far Side here
a pass and a breakaway moving in and Elvis very
calmly just plays that Puck and hole Johnny set
out there now with Jenner L I like this move get
Johnny going out there with the big boy [Applause]
ample opportunity here for the Blue Jackets to tie
it up Dan forth works hard sends it ahead save jar
rebound scores Alexander texier on the rebound
it's tied at three and it's all three guys on
a line change here as they come on with speed
the Blue Jackets warsky got possession and he
gets it to the right guy and it's a speed up the
ice of Dan fourth right there little chip now it's
compete and you can see all three guys involved
as carali gets it texier is trusting on the weak
side but Dan forth with two guys on him gets
it to Shan Crowley and then it's a just a five
shots for the Blue Jackets on the power play yeah
some really good look some lineing fentii Jenner
goodro gel Crosby into the slot
comes up high this one drilled
scores Penguins after after killing off the
penalty come back again and have regained
the lead on a bullet of a shot Crosby's
going to make this play in one motion you
see M leener has to respect that he tries to
get set for this play and what a pass I mean
it's just an incredible play we see kryder
do this all the time but Crosby's going to
come around the backside Carlson waits for
him times it perfectly and that's a tough
Play to save for Elvis M leans as it's a ramp
Play here's lining long shot blocked it's out
of the Zone hustling to a receivers it
gets there ahead of rust well into the
final minute on here for L gets away from him
Russ to Crosby and there it is the hatrick
goal 16th career hatrick second career-wise
against the Blue Jackets the hats are coming out
of the stands and the Penguins lead by two here's
the play by line here goes Severson he just wants
to get that pass that layer and here he can't do
it it's a Nissan move of the game as the hatch
are coming down here in Columbus and from there
it's just this play that goes off that stick of
Patty lineing not a great pass but a great pass
to rust he knows where Crosby is he wants him to
get a hatrick and Russ just says here's [Applause]
sth that'll do it 53 the final Pittsburgh win it